this is Susan hi Susan yesterday the
very lady came in and spoke to Jennifer
Anderson he sounded so calm and cool he
was really articulate and I went what
happened this isn't funny Jadey like had
some weird confidence around Jennifer
Aniston give me some advice for the
first time
yes I'm 39 years old you really haven't
yeah I really have you have any advice
for him weed are you smoking it are you
eating it well I think that's part of
the process
tomorrow we're trying to figure out what
how to do things because JD's such a
freak on Sunday we did like a little
soundcheck so I'm standing there JD's
here on Sunday and my wife and I walk
into the room where JD is and JD's just
staring at the wall in the opposite
direction of me and my wife I never
turned finally just like gonna say
something cuz I know this could I see
this guy every day of my life I go I go
hello JD how are you you can turn around
and say hello to me he's looking like
away from me and then he goes oh hello I
think this is a weird [ __ ] he's
got Asperger's or some [ __ ] oh you
definitely should be tested we should
get you like life tested on the spectrum
you we're talking to other people like
out you were looking out into this court
no no no I looked at you and I go you
don't say hello to me when I walk in
it's like you never met me before it's
like we don't see we don't share a giant
office nothing it's like you it's like
I'm a stranger yeah and then my wife
standing there who knows you and even
took you shopping and Bobo has a history
with you no you did I go JD by the way
this is Beth is my wife Wow hey JD
puppet yeah right exactly but with
Jennifer Aniston for some reason you
were like a bon vivant you were mr.
America I was I was actually very
nervous I felt very nervous yeah yeah
when you're nervous you speak well well
it's like it's like that scene in old
school when Will Ferrell has to do that
debate and it just comes out pouring out
of him in an eloquent way and
yeah but no I I think you were talking
you started talking to salads let me
talk to salad was weird that you and
Jennifer Aniston I saw on the New York
Post calm calm had a big picture with
you and Jennifer Aniston was the wit
most surreal thing you gotta look at
it's very surreal and you guys were
featuring it like you're almost like a
couple start I like to apologize the
right Hollywood har Meyer the :